au venezuela les deux américains arrêtés
accusés d'avoir tenté je cite d'envahir
le pays par la mer pour renverser
nicolas maduro aurait avoué ils seront
jugés de façon juste selon la sémantique
du président vénézuélien
des déclarations qui interviennent
quelques heures après celle de mike
pompéo le secrétaire d'état américain
dément toute implication de washington
françois disque et vite
le président du venezuela la sur les
deux américains arrêtés dimanche à une
heure de route au nord de caracas ont
été inculpés et ont avoué avoir organisé
une tentative d'invasion
ils sont bien traités et seront jugés de
façon juste par un tribunal vénézuélien
a précisé nicholas maduro qui réitère
ses accusations contre donald trump
j'ai d'ores et déjà ordonné au ministre
des affaires étrangères d'envoyer un
ensemble de rapports avec les vidéos
correspondante avec le contrat
correspondant de cette attaque menée par
le gouvernement des états unis et donald
trump contre le venezuela qui se joint à
l'action en justice devant la cour
pénale internationale
bien entendu nous l'ajouterons au procès
au cours de cette conférence de presse
nicolás maduro a diffusé la vidéo de
l'interrogatoire d'un des deux
américains arrêtés luc denham une
séquence dans laquelle il explique avoir
été engagé par jordan goudreau fondateur
de silver copie aux essais sociétés
privées de sécurité dont l'objectif est
d'entraîner des hommes en colombie pour
envahir le venezuela est renversé le
président mamadou sow qui commandent
jordan le président donald trump qui lui
a donné les armes les uniformes jordan à
travers silver coop
un peu plus tôt dans la journée le
secrétaire d'état américain mike pompéo
avait réaffirmé la non implication de
washington dans cette opération
mais il prévient caracas le gouvernement
américain fera tout pour rapatrier ses
deux anciens membres des forces
spéciales américaines
il n'y a aucune implication directe du
gouvernement américain dans cette
opération
nous allons travailler là dessus c'est
une question consulaires dans le sens où
chaque fois que des américains sont
détenus quelque part ne travailleront
pas les récupérer
nous allons enclencher le processus d'
essayer de trouver un moyen si ce sont
réellement des américains qui sont là
bas
et si nous pouvons trouver une issue
nous voulons récupérer chaque américain
si le régime de nicolás maduro décide de
les garder nous utiliserons tous les
moyens à notre disposition pour tenter
de rapatrier
il en va de notre responsabilité accusé
par nicholas maduro d'avoir recruté des
mercenaires pour fomenter cette
opération avec jordan goudreau
l'opposition vénézuélienne dénonce un
faux servant je cite à justifier une
tentative d'arrestation de roanne why do
une arrestation qui serait l'ultime
erreur de nicolás maduro
selon washington